it's now my great pleasure to introduce
the co-directors of our newest reality
program and brain mind and consciousness
who will say a few words Mel good Dale
is the professor and director of the
brain and mind Institute at Western
University a fellow of the royal society
of london he is a leader in the study of
visual pathways in the brain and the
coordination of movement and perception
and patients with neurological
conditions his partner in this endeavor
is Adrian Owen adrian is also a
neuroscientist base of Western his work
focuses on disorders of consciousness
and neurodegenerative diseases he is a
Canada excellence research chair
philosophy you don't know that program
it was started about the Government of
Canada to recruit to Canada true
scientific stars from anywhere in the
world to to lure them with both money
and with great colleagues like milkydale
so Adrian comes to Canada to Western
from Cambridge University please join me
in welcoming both Mel Goodell and Adrian
own
well you've got a double act I'm Mel
Goodell and as you just heard him a
co-director of the Azrael a program in
brain mind and consciousness at sea far
it was he expected the short guy to
stand on this side here sorry I made you
knowing and washed your notes I i am the
other co-director of the Azeri program
in brain mind and consciousness mel and
i would like to start by cecilie
thanking me as really foundation for for
this amazing gift it's going it's a gift
it's going to allow us to bring together
some of the smartest people on the
planet to try and tackle what is it must
be one of the most fundamental yet
elusive problems remaining in science
today and that is how does the human
brain give Ryan give rise to the human
mind in fact the mission really is an
ambitious one I mean to understand how
it is that the three pounds of wet we're
inside our skull gives rise to every
thought every feeling every intention
that we experience as we move through
the world and how it can go wrong in so
many different ways the relationship
between particularly brain and mind is
something that actually we all really
care about whether we are parents taking
a young child for their first football
hockey game and we're concerned about
the effects of concussion to the Dalai
Lama who has contemplated how the brain
gives rise to awareness and our sense of
moral responsibility and our sense of
who we are and what we are and
everything everything comes down to
consciousness even down to what we're
going to learn about tonight which is
how how it is that we develop an
aesthetic appreciation for everything in
the world around us the relationship
between brain mind and consciousness
impacts education it impacts social
dynamics creativity ethics moral
responsibility medicine clearly
and the understanding of how drugs and
disease affect our brains in this new
CFR program we're bringing together some
of the brightest minds on the planet
including cognitive neuroscientist like
ourselves neurologists geneticists other
biologists anthropologists psychologists
computational scientists philosophers
even artists to tackle some of the
biggest questions about how the human
brain works how it gives rise to
consciousness it's really the sort of
endeavor that could be funded only
through a program like so far and thanks
Alan so much for allowing us the
privilege of getting this program off
the ground one that allows us to bring
together a really diverse group of
people on a regular basis to work
towards a common goal understanding how
the brain gives rise to the human mind
now our program is already running let
me just tell you about a few of the
issues that we are starting to tackle so
one of the issues were very interested
in is what precisely are the other
specifically human aspects of
consciousness why for example do other
species not appear to respond as we do
to great art or great music what about
the the what about how consciousness
develops when does it start how do
infants and children acquire
consciousness somewhere on the
trajectory from a zygote and a fetus to
an infant a toddler and an adult
consciousness emerges well where and how
does that happen we have absolutely no
idea but we're starting to pursue that
question you've all recently seen i'm
sure alfa GO computer software doing
amazing things that even in some in some
senses outrun the human brain but will a
machine or a piece of software like
alpha go ever achieve consciousness
that's something that we want to find
out what about so-called disorders of
consciousness the area that I work in we
know already that some condition
is like coma and vegetative state can
Harbor covert consciousness
consciousness there is not apparent from
clinical examination well one of the
things we want to know is can we unlock
these minds can we can we get these
people can to express themselves and
finally for the rest of us how is it
that we can all enjoy the experience of
seeing fine art of sway to the sound of
a classical symphony or why is it that
we will cry at the same scene in our
favorite movie just last week we came
back from a really exciting meeting of
our program at the Royal Society in
London England the topic was biomarkers
of consciousness how events in the brain
or other aspects of our biology are
correlated with conscious processing
versus unconscious processing but simply
how can we measure consciousness how can
we measure its work in the brain seif
our fellows and guests were drawn from
many different countries and many
different disciplines just as an example
she Anna Jocelyn from sick kids was
there and she talked to us about her
exciting work using animal models to
study the cellular and molecular
mechanisms that accompanied learning and
how eventually there might be applied to
understanding even higher cognitive
functions even consciousness one of the
talks and discussions I really loved was
by a seat credere from from Paris who
who spoke to us about his studies is
very recent studies using EEG or
electroencephalogram eat ooh to look at
what happens when we sleep and his
latest data shows us that people process
far more information than we than we
ever thought possible even when they're
very deeply asleep and seemingly
completely unconscious rafi Malik from
the basement Institute in Israel was
there and he talked to us about his
really groundbreaking work recording
from single neurons in patients with
epilepsy with indwelling electrodes to
track the electro genic focus using this
cutting-edge paradigm Ratheon his
colleagues have shown that when people
are presented with stimuli that are
subliminal that
they can't actually see they will get
activation in visual cortex at the back
of their brain but when it emerges into
perception and they see those stimuli
suddenly you get a wave of activity that
spreads from these early visual areas
forward in the brain to the frontal
lobes the kind of ignition if you like
of consciousness and these kinds of
experiments I think are going to teach
us a lot about the involvement of these
higher-order areas in delivering up
conscious experience so we're only just
starting but all this work is getting us
closer to understanding the relationship
between brain activity and consciousness
at the experiences that we have all
around us in the world every day Mel and
I and all of the the other fellows in
the Israeli program in brain mind and
consciousness are tremendously excited
about this program we can't wait for
future meetings and the collaborative
research projects that are already
starting to emerge from these these
amazing meetings so what does all of
that have to do with what's happening
tonight in a few minutes well one
question is already heard that we're
particularly interested in is the
biological basis of art and aesthetics
what it is about the human brain that
allows us to create and enjoy art
storytelling and of course music indeed
is the relationship between the brain of
music that brings us together this
evening and we are so grateful to
Michael and Sonia Kerner for their
foresight and helping us make this
happen thank you very much I might also
say once more a big shout out to Robert
Satori and Laurel trainer who put in so
many hours with the gryphon trio and
Julian is Rolla in pulling this together
we're incredibly grateful so it was a
little more for me to say I'll hand back
the podium to Alan thank you for coming
and hope that you all have a wonderful
evening thank you
Thank You melon Thank you Thank You
Adrienne I think you have a sense now
why I have the best job in camera or
perhaps the world I have a front seat
Gold sees I guess of the best science
going on in the planet I only mentioned
cosmology we have a cosmology and
gravity program that's made up of the
best astrophysicists on this planet
Adrian and Mel talked about the Alpha go
game well that alpha go game was
actually developed by students who
worked in of troughs who have led our
program on artificial intelligence all
of deep learning that you read about
that really is launching autonomous cars
and smart robots etc all started in
another CFR program that's now called
learning machines and brains so we have
about 400 fellows from 18 countries and
so you're seeing a small subset a good
subset but a small subset of really the
fantastic scientists that make up the
CFR fellow family so thank you very much
melon Adrian I want it just conclude by
thanking everyone who has contributed to
putting this evening together Julie
desyrel I'm thanking you in advance and
members of the gryphon trio Robertson
Laurel and most of all Naomi Stephanie
the entire azrieli foundation thank you
all very much now finally before you go
into the auditorium where as you go in
you'll pass by a table and that table
has they're handing out what are called
AR DS so AR DS our audience response
devices ok so they won't hurt you
and they won't change your brain in any
way so don't don't be afraid but please
take one because during the show you're
going to be asked to provide some
feedback too what's going on on the
stage ok it's part of we're all part of
an experiment that's going on this
evening and we'll see what happens with
that so this will be an interesting
little experiment so thank you all once
again for coming and I hope we all enjoy
the show thank you very very much
you